[Musique]
justin trudeau croyait avoir décroché la
lune l'ornement l'astronaute julie
payette gouverneur général du canada
je suis tellement privilégié tellement
honorée d'avoir la chance de vous
représenter
mais l'atterrissage a été difficile
radio-canada a pu confirmer auprès de
plusieurs sources que madame payet
s'adapterait mal à son rôle son
tempérament serait difficile et les
relations tendues avec son personnel
depuis son arrivée trois personnes qui
occupaient des postes de direction ont
quitté leurs fonctions
c'est le chaos communication aux
ressources humaines et à la chancellerie
des distinctions honorifiques
la gouverneure générale aime faire les
choses à sa manière expliquent nos
sources elle s'ajusterait mal par
exemple aux exigences du dispositif de
sécurité de la grc qui l'entourent à
cela s'ajoutent des conflits d'horaire
julie payette aurait retardé la tenue de
la cérémonie de sanction royale du
projet de loi sur la légalisation du
cannabis en juin lorsqu'on lui avait
demandé à la dernière minute l'apprend
question qu'on doit se poser c'est est
ce que madame payette était au courant
vraiment du niveau de travail qu'on
demande
en général et si oui pourquoi l'at elle
pas
le gouvernement trudeau s'est porté à la
défense de la gouverneure générale
qu'est ce que c'est pas le gouvernement
qui va déterminer zonage est celle qui
détermine en fonction des son équipe de
fonctionnaires qui sont les priorités du
vendeur général
moi j'ai confiance à cette décision la
corde le bureau de madame payette a
répondu ceci la gouverneure générale a
d'excellents rapports avec l'équipe du
bureau de secrétaire du gouverneur
général avec qui elle a établi les
priorités de son mandat
ses relations avec le bureau du premier
ministre sont aussi excellentes malgré
tout l'opposition et prix occuper les ce
rôle est un portail à des projets de loi
qui a des parents et ils doivent se
concrétiser si les choses s'enveniment
le gouvernement trudeau pourrait être
confronté un dilemme quoi cet expert le
gouvernement va devoir soit défendre la
grande halle nous mettre plus de
pression sur l 2
repenser son niveau de travail ses rangs
sur la difficulté pour le gouvernement
évidemment c'est difficile
n'est pas nécessairement une image qu'on
voulait donner à la charge le
gouvernement trudeau espérait que
l'arrivée de julie payette donnerait un
vent de fraîcheur à une institution
ancré dans la tradition pour l'instant
ses façons de faire semble plutôt avoir
créé la résistance pas du renouveau ici
louis blouin radio canada ottawa